aniversario de dos años de guerra en una
situación preocupante muy preocupante
para la población especialmente a nivel
económico después de años de destrucción
de muertes de que más de la mitad de la
población tuvo que dejar sus hogares
muchos de ellos
5 millones fueron a vivir a otros países
ahora la realidad es tu ves que se
quedaron
[Música]
[Aplausos]
sigue devaluándose los salarios ya no
les alcanzan para nada el poder de
adquisición es mínimo lo que lleva mucha
gente a buscar ayuda y organizaciones
voluntarias son bastante escasas en el
país especialmente en esta ciudad como
raha hemos visto mucha gente las
familias más pobres yendo a buscar
comida porque no tienen por qué comprar
y cada momento se nos acercan más porque
la población es más pobre no te
preocupan las autoridades
de cultivo para estas ideologías como
grupos extremistas como el estado
islámico que se presenta en una ciudad
como raha especialmente con esas células
urbanas que pueden aparecer en cualquier
momento